the jurogan experience were you
surprised that they decided to have uh
usman
and um ii um
surprise no because i know like it says
about money right putting acid in the
sea and
um i think if the fight 10 out of 10
times
i think usman pro win nine probably um
it's a good entertaining fight for the
fans but
martial artists is one of them fights
right he's like
it wasn't just going to go out there and
probably grapple him again probably um
i want to see what what moz vidal can do
with the camp
you know because clearly he wasn't
prepared
physically you know i mean take a fight
on six days notice there's no way you
can really be prepared
no he was training he wasn't you had
like wrestling coaches like
i remember watching him um he was he was
like getting
good good good training and you know we
weren't like sitting on on the couch for
the last
like six months then take six days and
and and four right
but you know as well as i know there's a
difference between just training
yeah and then preparing for a fight
right yeah yeah um
what do you think he beats him no i'm
not saying that
but what i am saying is there were some
very interesting moments in that fight
where he was outstriking him yeah but
you know kamara was just
so strong it's such a good result and
finger dropped him um
dropped him the other day so um it'd be
a good fight i've been watching it for
sure you know but
um i think if i had to put money on it
i'll probably go um
usman for the for the win again well
once he you know i mean
once a guy beats a guy he's always going
to be the favorite to fight again but
it's just it's just uh
it's an interesting fight i i just i'm
very i'm
i'm excited to see how maz vidal
performs with a camp
no it'd be good it'd be good i'd love to
see as well but i can't see
what he could do different you know he's
doesn't come out again be
what he'd what he does he didn't swing a
single thing for the fences and
try to knock him out he wasn't gonna um
high guard and just grapple him and
i was going to see what he does
different unless it catches him and
knock him out i was currently um
what he does differently when uh you and
mozart all got at it
at that post fight press conference
london like did you expect that a fight
was going to come after that that you
would eventually
um yeah for sure 4k next that's that's
the next fight right
straight away and to have it like now
it's like two years two for two and a
half years it's like
we're still in fort yet i've been
calling him out ever since and
the ufc wants it uh but you just keep
turning it down and said uh
no you don't want to fight well that's
the weird thing it's like you're
at an elite level the top of the food
chain in terms of your skill level
yeah but you're not as known as you
should be
with the skill level that you have it's
just i mean it's like
it's it's like you're the best kept
secret in the division it's weird
yeah it's it's a weird thing but it'll
change yeah it's going to change 100
it's coming i can feel it it's changing
you know slowly but
i think number number one should fight
number two right number two
two number three is right number four
and that's the way it should be right
but it's like
i'll have to have to like go to like
number 13 to fight below i'd like to go
to fight hamza because
all these guys are like devious right
they were just demanding like kobe for
example
just demanding title shots like just got
beat like one fire to go
um knocked out one fight ago right no he
he beat tyron after that yeah so yeah
yeah so tyrone then
beat tyrone and yeah um in fourth sense
right so far to his mind then he'd be it
was just tyrant right
there's one fight right i think so after
that i think it's just a woodley fight
yeah i'm sure it was pretty sure
so i don't i don't think you you deserve
a tower shot he just got beat
like convincingly you weren't like a it
was it was a close fight to be fair but
it did get stopped you know so
i don't think she'd get a touchdown
straight away um
so that's a fight you would like because
we fight yeah
now yeah for sure 100 um obviously i
went to the tower shop with not a
fighting
um the only reason why i would say it'd
be better for you to fight someone
before the title shot is just to get the
hype out
yeah just yeah so that with the
pay-per-view gets built up so that you
you'll get more money
yeah yeah bigger deal not for sure i
won't be sitting around waiting for the
uh i'll be fighting you know so we're
trying to we're trying to get it and
uh kobe is a weird weird one so we don't
know what's gonna happen but we're
trying to get a fight done
yeah well the one thing that does come
with colby is a lot of attention
and that's that's the good the good part
of it is a good fight technically
you know um i think i think the top all
the guys are all similar right
and skill set what they're going to do
when they fight me right yeah you know
they're going to come to wrestle
if the fight is going to come to the
rest of kobe's and come to wrestle um
bilal doesn't come to wrestle don't i
know what they're going to do you know
it says it's easier to prepare for them
you can
um i was saying before you kind of like
swap them out so when when hamzap fell
out
i was okay put anyone in because they're
all all gonna do the same thing anyway
so just swap another one in and uh
that's that's what it was
so normal they're all gonna try to yeah
yeah yeah i didn't try grappling what
that means nothing to me you know i've i
i feel good when it with the grappling i
feel good or just striking and
um i just can't wait to show my skill
set and show
what i'm about i haven't done what i
could yet in the game but i want to show
it and i'm going to show it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience